if you're an HTML programmer you've
likely Seen Crazy nested code like this
ugly code is one thing but the real
problem is that your UI disappeared
because you've got a bunch of other junk
stacked on top of it this might make you
want to gouge your eyes out but luckily
there's a better approach first find 3D
view in your browser Dev tools you see
the browser needs to go through multiple
steps to turn your code into actual
pixels on the screen composite view will
visualize how these steps take place in
3D which is super useful for debugging
animations but when something doesn't
show up in the Dom the typical solution
is to increase the zindex until it shows
up but don't do that blind because in 3D
view we can visualize the zindex of
every single element and finally Dom
mode allows us to visualize HTML hell it
creates a heat map that shows how all
the elements are nested and you can even
customize the colors the more complex
the result the more it means your
website sucks pretty awesome but to use
3D view there's just one catch it's only
available in Microsoft Edge